here we go Joe Rogan says Democrats have
no hope in 2024 election other than
President Biden 80 dying like very soon
holy crap Joe would he say that too that
was it Dave Smith that's perfect was he
talking to uh who is it says does it say
he was yeah it was Dave Smith
Harris Trump debate
actually be brilliant that'd be awesome
it would be there's not going to be
debates though right no not not primary
not if it's Biden I mean if if Biden
dies or something or if something
happens where Biden isn't in uh there's
gonna have to be debates they'll have to
be CNC so they're not going to host any
um I think Trump is pushing foreign
but if Biden dies or if Biden's not the
one guy they're gonna have to you'll
have to have people well there's so much
I saw a poll that RFK could take
um I think 14 of Biden's vote could
maybe siphon off now obviously you know
polls that are this far out are
completely hypothetical
um obviously there's so much news
reporting that's going to happen until
the actual election so you never know
but it would be a siphon like Ross Perot
and it could help the Republican um I
mean Kanye did that with Trump
but I
realistically I want Trump to win
idealistically I want Dave Smith to win
David yeah great yeah I would love to
see I would love to see Dave win to see
real libertarian policies it's not even
about real libertarian it's about a real
person fair enough Trump trump has a lot
of deals with uh with bad people well he
brought in he brought in bad people I
think he I think in a lot of ways he's
the best president of my lifetime
especially on foreign policy the economy
was pretty good but I don't know I don't
know enough about the Clinton years I
hear was actually a massive economic
expansion but uh for me as an adult
there's no question that Trump was the
best what Bush Obama get out of here and
then uh there's
bush bush and Obama is is what I I can
tell you about and it was garbage and
then we get Trump and there's bad things
the lockdowns found you and all that
stuff I was told there'd be a wall but
the foreign policy stuff was a side to
behold yeah and it was very good there
so as as a former president I'm like
that's that's probably who it's gonna be
you're never going to get someone
perfect but Dave Smith's like a real
dude yep and I like as much as you were
talking about or to your point about
Trump like the worst thing about Trump
was Trump's uh Personnel selection yeah
you know the the people that stabbed
Trump in the back the most were people
that Trump had put into you know put
into positions of power in the
bureaucracy so I think that that Dave
Smith would be a a far better uh
far better mediation of the power of the
federal government and I do think that
Smith would go in and really like take a
serious ax to the bureaucracy in a way
that Trump probably wouldn't I think the
only guarantee you have to actual
actually seeing everybody get fired is
Dave Smith yeah Will he win no I mean
come on let's be real one of the problem
with Trump's Personnel selection was his
hiring criteria unfortunately was how
much they like Donald Trump which is
very exploitable if you're trying to
take advantage of him yeah
with so many people where the second
they lit they leave you know when when
you change a political ideology it's
very gradual it's not like you do a 180
in every issue but they feel like Alyssa
Farah who sorry okay it's all right here
there's only people like Alyssa Farah
and countless others you can think of
where every single political belief
changed the second they left the White
House and it's just clear oh you're an
opportunist you were taking advantage of
him and you might not even believe these
new beliefs it's just uh for the sake of
power or whatever there's so many people
like that didn't didn't Caitlin Collins
work at Daily Caller yeah there was
there was an article she wrote called
the top 10 hottest blacks and what I'm
not getting and she got them to remove
her name from like the the header once
she moved over something but it's still
on there if you Google it's like top top
hottest blacks or something it really is
remarkable you can see people's true
colors when they do things like which is
Oliver Darcy used to do like uh leftist
exposed website or whatever and the
second CNL from a check he uh and and he
also defended the alt-right really
Oliver Darcy defended white white
nationalist Free Speech huh yeah he
interviewed he asked me about it because
I'd commented on Twitter about how they
shouldn't be banning these people
because people have a right to free
speech this was back in like 2016. he
worked for business I think it was
Business Insider then he gets hired at
CNN and he's like I'll change my
opinions to whatever you want them to be
that's the modern era that's probably
how it's always been to be completely
honest you do notice that when people
move to a network you you generally kind
of you look at chameleon you kind of you
know there are certain views you have to
have to get ahead so you just it becomes
very easy to hold them when you need to
well it is done but it's in their
financial incentive so it becomes easier
to believe dumb things very easy for a
lot of people to justify things and
money becomes involved that's one of the
hardest things for people to to realize
is that it's always going to be a
problem to find authenticity when that
much money is on the line correct yeah I
just man there's so few people of
conviction and like let's just call it
testosterone that's what we need we need
just like some testosterone raging dude
like natural of course he eats a lot of
beef who's just like I am sick of this
you're fired you're fired you're fired
but so is Trump that was a show Trump
was Trump is all kind of like that but
there was a lot of like okay I guess
fauci's okay yeah you know what I mean
and it's like bro just I that's what I
do like about Trump is he'll get to that
point just be like nope done out by you
know if you're fired but then with Burks
and fauci it's like come on man
you know so so look I will say he's the
best that I've seen in my life because
like what am I comparing him to Obama
and Bush so what are they are they
saying in this that the Democrats won't
win if Biden runs is that what they're
saying I can't I can't see an 81 year
old did you see his uh he put out a
video his re-election his announcement I
couldn't even understand what he was
saying
I mean he didn't even do he sat no he
sat in the basement all the way up to
2020 and he still won so I don't know
what's changed there's no actual
accomplishment that he can point to that
the American people are gonna say yes we
feel good about this they'll go ahead
and they'll list off a laundry list of
things that they think that are good but
the results haven't haven't materialized
for the average person the average
person generally has a negative outlook
about the about the Paul the way the
politics are shaping up in the in the
country where the country's economy is
going there's a negative sentiment
across the board for the vast majority
of Americans and he has no no plan and
to address any of it it's all just like
hey remember how bad Donald Trump is
that's no that was the whole ad here's
here's I'll tell you what I think
happens I think when you're running for
president
they're they're you know you're you're
up there you're pulling really well and
then behind the scenes you got the DNC
the RNC people depending which party and
they're like you're gonna make it man
you're doing really well you're our pick
the moment you get elected and you're
standing up on stage and smiling you
walk backstage you they shake your hands
and say now that you are are uh present
elect why don't why don't you come with
me so it really works they they bring
into the back room and they say why
don't you have a seat Mr President have
a seat right here Mr president-elect and
then they show you a picture of John F
Kennedy and then they just stand there
quietly and then you're just like what
is this and they just they still
responding for the show like it makes
sense in Congress if everyone has dirt
on everyone else and there's a certain
level of decorum that if you breach it
all comes out like remember with Madison
cawthorne where yeah he made some
comment about Like Cocaine sex storages
and within a week there was 10 hit
pieces that could not videos organically
it was someone had it in a vault
somewhere and went all right you cross
the line sorry you gotta destroy you now
and they did and it worked yeah yeah
well you've got primary didn't he yeah
yeah and the thing is to the guy who
replaced you never hear about yeah so so
I mean it's probably better just to go
under the rug but imagine being that
District you had prominence you had
someone speaking a voice that was giving
your District you know prominence and
now nothing oh well yep all because of
dirty pictures but that's that's the
thing about Trump people are like why
didn't he pardon Julian Assange yo
because they shut up they walked up to
him and they said you want to partner
goes that's right they showed him a
picture of John F Kennedy and then he
was like what's this and they just stare
at him they don't say anything and he's
like okay okay I get it they're like we
are mad about the things you're doing
but that is something else
granted I'll be honest I think the
reason Trump didn't pardon Assange is
because he wanted Assange here to
testify for him
Trump wanted Assange because Assange
could prove certain things that Trump
wanted proved as it pertains to the Deep
State and Trump did not care about
Julian Assange as an individual he cared
more about the United States
so that created this
unfortunate circumstance because
Assange shouldn't have been in the
Ecuadorian Embassy to begin with he
should have been a free man he should
have been fine but this has just gotten
worse and worse and worse at this point
though we had Don Jr on the show we
called in saying got to Pardon him maybe
maybe now that you know we'll get a
second Trump term he's going to be like
don't need that guy anymore you're
pardoned I I really do feel like if
Trump gets reelected you're gonna have
all your dreams come true and I do mean
it what I should clarify with like okay
not literally 100 of everything all the
political dreams but I think Trump's
going to be like pardoned I think he's
going to Pardon Assange I think he's
going to Pardon Snowden I think he'd
pardon Ross Albrecht I think he's going
to end a bunch of Wars he's going to be
like this is it he went easy on his
first turn because he want to get
reelected and do a this is what they
always do they try to do a little bit
for four years and then a lot in their
last term if Trump gets reelected he's
going to be like I'm pressing the reset
button yeah well it would be you know
there would be no restraints on him this
time around he kind of knows how to
maneuver the system now I mean obviously
he had no girlfriend experience going in
but it's now going to be sort of
scorched Earth hopefully
um but you know it is a tough you know I
guess Hill to climb as well there was a
four six million vote deficit last cycle
and how are we going to close that and
then you know if there is a voter fraud
angle then there's you know most of the
the key Battleground states are either
run by democrats and their legislatures
now or the governorship so it is an
uphill battle there but that was the
biggest mistake whinging about losing
and blaming your failure is on
this next election what we need to hear
is Democrats making those accusations
yes like they did with Trump in Russia
the thing with Trump is the rhetoric
pulls very well with Republicans but
Independents hate it yeah and you know
you need to get their votes so it's it's
good with the base but they don't want
to hear that because tribalism is
we can't lose we're the best this is a
mistake Independents are just like dude
convince me yeah and so coming out and
and this was big for me Trump
complaining about 2020 I was like I'm
done with this I'll vote for DeSantis
now that Trump's back and saying you
know these policy things and and calling
out the machine and going to East
Palestine now I'm like okay that I like
yeah that's better than the Santa can
you just do more of that like they use
Palace kind of stuff or even videos
where he's like at UFC and you see
people like people I don't know if
something makes me proud to be an
American just to see someone have that
effect and well just when she's the
president that can can be among the
people and act in a normal way Joe Biden
cannot interact with people at all in
fact checks say like a five-year-old the
other day someone asked him where do you
where was the last country you went and
he was like I don't know and someone a
kid goes Ireland and it was like 12 days
ago it was like two days it wasn't 12
days it was like the weekend it was it
was it over the week okay so it was
within a week it was within a week then
yeah yeah yeah
yeah ridiculous did I go to Ireland like
you did Joe oh right it's a it's
incredible that that Joe Biden is the
president and the and that there aren't
people demanding that he gets but also
he's gonna walk into the office he's
gonna be like where's the coffee maker
and he's gonna press the launch nukes
button it is unfortunately a cell phone
though when you bring up him and
fetterman because they did beat us so
yeah well it's not so much that
Democrats are winning it's that
Republicans are so good at losing
Republicans are the best that's why I
call them the power bottoms
they like to be I have a feeling that
they just like losing and they like
complaining about losing so please send
oh please send us more money please give
us more of your support because we just
for some reason we're losing so much the
the Washington generals that's how we
describe yeah we'll turn it around
that's what it seems like it's I mean I
don't I don't want to get it like I
don't want to be so black-filled and be
like oh yeah the Republicans are just
totally controlled opposition but that's
really what it says what do they
actually do I wouldn't say like name a
republican policy that's like been
signed in the past I don't know four
years literally the only thing that
that's been I can talk about state level
easily even with Trump like the war was
supposed to be his number one crowning
achievement and I think we got 500 miles
and and you know there's debate it
doesn't count as new wolves who was
repairing all the wall definitely does I
would say yes but if it's non-functional
it doesn't exist so we got but we still
got like 1500 but it works 2 000 miles
so yeah like I'll give Trump credit for
that he's a big ass guy he comes on he's
like we're going to build a 30-foot
concrete wall from sea to shining C very
beautiful very the best and uh but what
we got was Triple layer Bollard fencing
in high in high risk areas so that's a
there's a bit of a nothing but it's huge
this is this is this actually is a big
deal so what happens is the left frames
it is though because Trump didn't build
a big concrete wall he lost and
conservatives are like yeah and then you
look at the actual numbers and it's like
the fence here used to be a 4 foot high
log it was a wooden post that you'd
you'd crawl under or walk right over and
Trump put a triple layer Bollard fence
there which reduced activity in this
area by 99 but because it wasn't a wall
the left says the wall was never built
yeah I mean it was probably built it's
just I want four times wow it wasn't it
but it wasn't right but I'll still say
I'll take it because Trump is a big ask
guy he will come out and say he wants a
30-foot concrete wall from sea to
shining sea and what do you get select
secure reinforcement of of these areas
so it's like did you get the the lottery
ticket dream no but you got an increase
in security which is a good thing and
and and to that point Hillary Bernie and
who Carey had all been talking about
voted for it in 2006 exactly they wanted
a border barrier so when Trump comes out
and he's like I'll do that thing they
didn't do everyone's like he's racist I
saw polling from q and it was on the
cultural values over time and a secure
border was like 80 to 90 support among
Republicans and Democrats and I'm not
kidding until like 2015. so yeah Trump
goes on the escalator all of a sudden
it's yeah I guess we need tens of
millions of people here for some reason
like it's just a weird knee-jerk
reaction but it was also something that
was always used as something they pushed
down the they pushed the can down the
road right they never actually get to it
it's just that both parties seem
interested in it in as much as that it
helped them on the campaign Trail most
of the time well for liberals their
their strategy is they say okay there's
10 million we can't Deport Olympia's
Logistics at school Etc and then 20
years from now they're gonna go okay
there's 20 million we can't afford
listen to this too many I guess we've
got to make them citizens and we you
know we know from the Reagan amnesty who
they're going to vote for and it's
Democrats so when did Sanctuary cities
come about so they I should let you guys
no good I was going to say they've been
around for a while but they became like
a badge of honor in defiance of trump
during his presidency and then of course
we see on our DeSantis you actually send
them illegals and they go well I mean
let's not get ridiculous here guys like
so so they they obviously don't want it
Martha's Vineyard was a sanctuary didn't
want them New York's a sanctuary doesn't
want that's more this Vineyard thing it
was awesome Master Class DeSantis yeah
you know what I mean that was brilliant
it was so good great the uh you talk
about
um the uh the voting patterns of of
immigrants and stuff like that and it is
likely that the people that are coming
over now are actually more conservative
than the left the progressive left uh in
the U.S today the the LGBT stuff is not
flying I don't know I don't know I don't
know if it matters I really do think
that they've done such a good job at
Brand it's not about whether they're
conservative it's how good of a job the
left has done at branding the right as
something bad and something you don't
want to vote for the the dot the default
culture in this in this country if you
look at entertainment music TV it's it's
leftist so first generation immigrants
actually culturally are more
conservative but they don't vote no and
their kids tend to be more assimilated
like for instance there was a poll
recently that most Muslims are actually
okay with homosexuality Now in America
so someone was like you know all this
time we were worried about Sharia in
America and instead we turned Islam gay
which I guess is you know you could call
it I don't know what you'd call that but
uh but no our country does have a sort
of left-leaning assimilation process by
default and it is the D like repeating
myself here but you know if you turn on
a TV a TV show even which is
non-political if there is a pro-life
character is it some wells rehearsed
star smart guy who cares about The
Unborn or is it some forming out the
mouth religious lunatic who does meth no
it is typically a blonde snooty woman
who's better than you you're just wrong
and I'm right yeah or it's someone like
harassing someone at an abortion clinic
yep there was there was an episode of
The Newsroom where and this takes place
I think it was in DC where the woman
makes like an anti-abo a pro uh abortion
comment on some TV show and then when
she comes back to her apartment it's all
been vandalized and I'm like it's DC
there's like four pro-life people like
what world are you creating in your head
where they would actually even happen
and what actually happens is it's antifa
who goes and smashes up pregnancy or
something pregnancy centers for for
people to keep there yeah we never do
that stuff yeah yeah conservatives are
like sitting down drinking Bud Light
yeah ignoring like you know well the
talking point is are you pro-life people
only care when they're a fetus you don't
care when they're born so they have all
these
but we have all this crisis pregnancy
centers that do these other services
except abortion and then they vandalize
them so pro-lifers are what is it like
for like I think five percent of
adoptions or something no they're like
five times more likely to adopt than
they would have choices yeah and then
the pro-choice people come up like if if
why don't why haven't you adopted and
it's just like you always see those
videos where the pro choicers walk up to
a pro-life protest and says have you
adopted a kid and they're like no I'm
like aha thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time